hello and welcome to this video playing
Prince panic video drugs from the
Netherlands and he's an Italian game
plan even before they're all started
with that the Italian game craze let's
see a for a thing yes so we probably get
some McCain I like this setup I also
play this King edge 898 but I remember
that we had this on the board zone and
it turned out to be that he played this
very well so it's this so we are saying
that my night on before it's not all
that well placed hmm let's could be
right that could definitely be right but
I have to do it anyway I think so okay I
didn't yes I always have 85 whenever I
start with this is friends but should
have 30 please and now define let's go d
5 that looks are quite active and have
some funky ideas and with night coming
to see three maybe check on you two and
so on it said something my light is also
protected now hmm maybe this isn't all
that bad page 3 93 ads Wow night oh come
on really you have new first thing later
I had versus your title I go 93 air I
move this first and think later what the
heck so I have to check on each rule I
mean I understand that this is not like
winning from you it what's going on here
the h3
hey this is hanging what happens here
actually clacking limits again who first
think later this way is he going to end
to hear I was thinking maybe this is
completely crazy what happens if i take
h3 and click into the cell is that
totally bonkers probably sm
thing is I don't ring no one else did
this might be completely out of the
Roses world but no normal voice also
didn't quite do it 27 27 is the deal I
wonder if it will take you can take f7
them and damn it he can take f7 this is
actually refueling this very very
directly and that's a shame okay that
was it was probably incorrect anyway but
you can take sm rook takes Queen takes
95 so
and it is it all that clear at the end
of all that I i still have is an
exchange up at the end I'm before I'm a
piece down here yeah I should turn with
hindsight and some novel moves would
have been better um anyway the ambition
of several this is a big issue
yeah 27th Bishop f7 King news bb6 was
covering age dream yeah okay that print
is crazy I should prove it stunk like
Nicole any way I could have played like
I don't know night c1 and just plain all
the more zone but I got carried away I
also lost the last couple of games
really badly or plate plate crab drawers
or something maybe I wanted to just do a
little bit too much down for my own good
the air again that's not exactly
difficult you know okay maybe oke to
hang some that's the thing not anyway
anyway it is this is kind of chaotic
jinx yeah okay I'm not aware of that but
I need to do something crazy now anyway
so we're to do that you go i can go to
e8 maybe and then to age 55 money
completely really but we are we getting
backing clicking it's a kind of thing
you know it's objectively lost but maybe
you can still put up with five hmm
hmm it takes you to create three this is
getting slightly interesting again look
f6 g6 and stuff like that it could be at
least irritating take that you just take
that okay so where do i think i can say
and i had don't I don't I cannot break
this the Queen will come there so either
you can take we should be too I'm
playing just such a bad chess at the
moment I can just take with the bishop
on 20 you didn't do it um wait
white mission teams I can take on you
for what's the deal I can take h3 at
least I've got 18 seconds maybe just
King takes that's the trick kingi to
call me also just this win yeah
unfortunately clock Queen takes Queen g
30 min and then I have one two now
connect to that Queen Queen Queen 23 Wow
check
check how he is just under control hey I
have no doubt me black poor things on
time so I felt like he loud a little
something which we probably probably not
enough yeah okay this just did not work
at all I mean this this was okay i think
i'm reasonably active him but ok here i
just have to do something normal yeah
and just take take take stuff yeah i
mean i saw that five is a problem but i
was really a kind of thinking that I can
yeah i cannot cover this sufficiently i
can do this yeah this is not a big issue
actually and yeah this is nice i can i
can use this Graham going to have six
and so on the engine gives an advantage
all nice and good but this is this is ok
with the opposite colored bishops and
this the bishop sitting on the form but
you can increase the pressure there and
this doesn't work at all probably I'm I
mean kind of surprised what happened I
know okay I have to go to ch that's sick
I was swinging 27 Quincy 8 is actually
not that clear okay okay you know and
put the engine says wide wins oh I see
and I understand I was kind of aware
that this is probably not a super
correct sacrifice but here at least I
get what I want I get this stimulation
and this is the position that I saw way
I felt like I might have ideas yeah 94
and so on I hear what i say engine give
it gives way to win okay so I don't have
any chance to see Eric him it wasn't so
clear to me I was just seeing this
betrayal sent you here check em
yeah i know i was just playing yea big
material down okay i could have taken c1
and g5 here that would have been
actually none still interesting okay you
for Jim and said simply it's just too
bad you could have taken e2 well that
wasn't even clear of it it's it's how
everything everything winds clock and
now I have control night f-4s drawn yeah
I should have done them from new book
takes okay I didn't have much time but
yeah this is better right you can he
doesn't have this probably climb nope
yeah I'm winning and then you you you
get this profibus everything try
everything treated ok so I had a chance
one shot it didn't materialize and it's
I guess correct oh I forgot to switch on
the end under the same this is some this
is not yet completely am in my system
that i can switch the analysis anyen i
have to flick a switch here to actually
display it yeah I'm sorry guys that is
not still yet completely embedded in my
system I mean I gave the evaluations
anyway before I introduce that future I
just felt like it doesn't hurt you add
it now because it doesn't take any
screen estate or whatever it just said I
have to actively switch it on two times
I have to switch it on and off in the
software not here and have to switch it
on and off in the recording software and
this is not yet completely they are not
say second nature to me ok guys thanks
for watching